[Music]
[Applause]
great we have you here at this salon of
the last performances here of the World
Science Festival and this afternoon's
topic is Beauty imbalance and we take
this occasion to have a discussion about
role of symmetry symmetry in science and
mathematics I will be representing the
sciences but also in the arts and I hope
this will for all of us be a wonderful
occasion to have a conversation that
might be even more broader ranging about
the connection between art and science
about the way we are guided by
mathematical principles or not what our
concepts of beauty are of order of chaos
of asymmetry I think it's just a grand
topic that I hope to explore with my two
panelists but also with you at some
point I think I won't really want to
direct give you the opportunities to ask
a few questions so I think we are all
set up for a lovely afternoon and I
think this is the right moment to call
my two participants as a center we have
the arts represented here both by design
and architecture and the first
participant of on to our first speaker
is the senior curator at the Museum of
Modern Art in the department of
architecture and designs is also MoMA's
founding director of research and
development and her work investigates
designs influence on everyday experience
please say hello to Paola Antonelli
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome Paulo please have a seat and
then our third participant is was also
joining us is the principal architect of
cell door for architects a 65 person
architectural design practice found at
the New York City in 1988 and the firm
creates public and private spaces that
manifests a clear and modern sensibility
to enduring impact
please welcome architect unabelle's
Eldora
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
both warm welcome to tu hieu Portobello
I think we said to the audience you know
we'll try to make this as a interacting
a conversation as possible and some part
also involved the audience and we have
kind of a grand topic today because it's
although we were asked to speak about
the role of symmetry and science and art
and we will do so in the beginning we
already said you know we are some sense
free since this also is basically the
last solo of the science festival to do
anything that we like we just can go
anywhere and I'm sure the audience will
be cheering us on but in order to
fulfill our contractual obligations or
to say we'll start by speaking a little
bit about symmetry and I think you know
my roles here to say a few words about
how symmetry is viewed from the
perspective of a mathematician or
physicist which which I am and then I
will ask each of you to say something
briefly about I would say kind of the
canonical just bring us up to speed is
what typically is kind of but the
typical thoughts are that go both in
design and architecture thinking about
symmetry so if I can start now I think
the kind of symmetries clearly all
around us know it's if it wouldn't be so
dark in this room I would kind of ask
the audience to point out symmetrical
objects but clearly the room is
left-right symmetric to a large extend
and now for us as if you look in nature
we see many manifestations of it from
just to set the stage from a
mathematical perspective asymmetry is
usually seen as a movement so you can
think of reflecting something turning
left and right or rotating something
around or shifting something along a
certain distance and in general if you
do that the object changes it's
different but if it's symmetric then it
doesn't so for instance a snowflake
if you return turn it around 60 degrees
it has a hexagonal symmetry it actually
comes back to itself if you have a
checkerboard you move it along one or
two steps then actually it returns to
its original state so it's also about
invariant
it also has to do with information or
some sense because it's it's a motion
you apply to an object that doesn't
create something else that's kind of the
traditional role of symmetries as it was
understood by the Greeks
and-and-and but then it has this
tremendous story in the development of
science where more and more and I hope
we can happen discussion bar it became a
guiding principle so I think if you
would say you're modern scientists and
particularly if you're interested in
understanding the deep structures in
reality what can you have as a guiding
principle but symmetry is one of these
so it's it's one of the most fundamental
tools we have and and it's it's in many
ways I think also a manifestation of the
order there's there are in nature that
we all love and that's why scientists
have a job because I could do something
to discover there and and understand so
this kind of mathematical perspective I
just sketch it here
I will come back at perhaps in later
stages but perhaps I can turn to you
Paula if you just in broad brushes
describe the role of symmetry in design
what what would you Annabel we'll talk
about architecture but in architects and
designers forever and human beings in
general in their making of things have
been trying to imitate nature because
nature does it best
and one of the rules that they have read
in nature is this rule of symmetry which
as we know very well is not completely
real but nonetheless by trying to
simplify in order to then imitate they
set out to first and foremost try
symmetry so try symmetry first and if it
doesn't work we can move on so when it
comes to the Museum of Modern Art it was
founded in 1929 and interestingly it was
founded by three ladies of the New York
society that wanted to show how non
symmetrical Modern Art really was I mean
in a way they were they were trying to
to show something other than the old
masters collection of their husbands so
I don't know
have that picture of the Museum of
Modern Art's trustees looking at the
Picasso paintings but already the museum
was founded in 1929 and in 1930 already
there were these major exhibitions of
Picasso and clearly if you think yeah
you see here the demoiselle d'Avignon in
the early 1930s that was the idea of the
arts that they wanted to show but at the
same time design instead was shown for
it's platonic beauty and if you don't
mind going to the images of those pieces
of machinery coils and propellers there
was an exhibition in 1934 at MoMA that
was considered revolutionary was a
design show it was called machine art
and there were all these propellers and
ball bearings and coils exactly this one
that were shown on white pedestals as if
they were Brancusi sculptures and
against white backgrounds it was really
revolutionary nobody had shown designed
that way and the two curators got a lot
of flack for it but to us this
exhibition that was so innovative at
that time might seem old-fashioned today
because it was all about the platonic
beauty and the symmetry of these highly
functional objects and Philip Johnson
the curator used this term platonic
beauty it's an image by the way because
of course Plateau describes these these
objects and it's it's as of course often
and he kind of it's interesting she also
said well we it's difficult to find a
entirely symmetric objects in nature
right but of course in plateaus that are
in my mind you know you can have the
perfect hexagon you can have the perfect
barrel so why come back to this point
why indeed these objects why did they
actually demonstrate symmetry what what
was what
telling us they were not the designers
were not trying to demonstrate symmetry
they were trying to make objects as
efficient as possible and therefore this
symmetrical quality was also connected
to the fact that most of them were parts
of engines we're like working things and
it seems we'll come back to that
like that symmetry is actually emerging
in some sense in terms of efficiency as
a goal exactly but then in the years
that went between the exhibition and
today so much has changed and especially
the concept of beauty has changed which
I know we're going to talk about later
so it's not only Picasso it's also
Almodovar it's David Bowie it's it's
Muhammad Ali nor just to talk about the
people that have brought us beyond the
idea that something perfectly balanced
is perfect and today we have come to
embrace in an age in which so many
things can be perfectly symmetrical
we've come to really in the world of
design and in the world also warka Tetra
to praise also a symmetry and lack of
balance
I remember how this is kind of jumping
but how excited I was when I saw that
there is a company in Portugal called
suta FEA which means ugly fruit that
takes all the kind of like nabhi and
kind of ugly fruits you know like the
apples that are completely asymmetrical
and that nobody wants and then sells
them to you for a very low price but
they were showing these beautiful
baskets of really weird yes instead of
the Platonic apple the the nonplatonic
is so much more interesting I must say
we saw briefly the image of the Apple
there and I think anybody at home if you
know it then it's it's it's a simple
fact but the fact that an Apple has a
fivefold symmetry many people do not
know so because usually you cut an apple
in four but you should cut it in five
just cut an apple through the middle and
be amazed you see the fivefold symmetry
I just want to kind of perhaps I can
almost summarize part of it you said is
that in design it's it's kind of a slow
weaning of this kind of idea of symmetry
and perfection and it has a goal and
going to more the asymmetric yeah but it
has to do also with the computational
power that has made us even more able
and more eager to get close to nature
yes and by using computational power
we've discovered that symmetry is not
the most important secret
we can use from nature in order to build
we go beyond yes you have you would have
a similar view on the role of symmetry
in architecture no good because I think
in the first place it's not necessary to
assign a value to either because I think
that symmetry is simply a fact it's a
state it's a concept and how it was used
in or how it is used in architecture is
in a way if you will a milestone
I think classical architecture obviously
is is very much based on the idea of
symmetry we can see it right there the
Greek only ever used even numbers for
example in in their colonnade so that
you never had a column in the middle
that then therefore had to split two
sides yes anyway and there are many
different kinds of symmetry but art
architecture and design probably in the
20th century or later 20th century have
given symmetry a bad rep as if like it's
boring to be symmetrical yeah I think
it's boring to be symmetrical in the
technical sense that if you if something
is perfectly symmetric if usually half
of it you have seen all of it right I
think it's uninteresting to always
assign values to everything I think
instead when you decide with deliberate
effort to make something asymmetrical
you still use symmetry as a reference
right so in some ways for me as an
architect today I think symmetry is a
tool as much as a symmetry is a tool and
there's the wonderful image of of Frank
Lloyd Wright's falling water that
is all about these ideas of approaching
nature and so on and so forth so I do
agree that symmetry isn't the only thing
that gives us consideration but it's a
point of departure in some ways and and
I think it's something that's hard to
get around already it transpired a
little bit particularly because we went
back to kind of the ancient times or
something that would you say that from
that frame of mind symmetry was kind of
equal to perfection or the two things
had something to do is it is it about
approaching something perfection is so
incredibly difficult that take the
Japanese concept for example where
perfection only happens if a break with
the complete surface actually happens
right I there is a saying that I can't
bring to mind right now but but in my
mind more than anything the reason why
symmetry is interesting is because
because it is a concept and because it
exists whether we like it or not
so to use that as a as a point of
departure is I think what's interesting
I was also wondering you know we if you
go back through actually the act of
making something I already said you know
if you if you were physicists and you
want to understand the world you you
look for guiding principles and some of
the guiding principles are that know if
you have symmetry considerations it
constrains very much your the forms of
the theories in which you describe the
world for instance know if you you won't
describe the world in a way that it
doesn't really depend how your precise
orientation is so there's like a doesn't
really matter whether the the forces in
the going north or east or west or south
so it's an important guiding principle
in some second both you start with you
Paola if you if you are and design
something what is it is symmetry also
kind of a tool is it something you could
kind of you
so I is it the guiding principle for
some designers or it is for some
designers there are so many forms of
design it's almost dizzying so there's
the good old fashioned furniture design
there's the product design which you
make things that go into them the market
the Ben you also have visualization
design in which you take data and you
render them in a visual form that makes
them very understandable
there is interface design there is video
game design so it really is as huge as
can be but let's go to the old-fashioned
kind of product design in most cases
product design tends to have symmetry as
a rule and it has to do with both
efficiency or the idea that you take
something with your hands and sometimes
it has to do also with manufacturing
constraints like I'm thinking when you
have rotation molding by definition
rotation molding with which so many bad
plastic furniture and you know many
plastic objects are made that's rotation
molding so you have a rotational
symmetry similarly with some with some
thermoplastics you have molds that are
injected injection molds that also are
symmetrical so I would say that when it
comes to physical objects in many most
cases yeah these are the objects from
the machine art show but if you think
also more recent objects just think of
the M&Ms or think of the post-it notes
or think of so many other objects they
tend to be symmetrical when you start
getting the kind of design that is more
generated by algorithms that is more
organic it tends to be not a rule but
something that happens if it has to
happen or not yes right well this kind
of does relate perhaps also to by Ray
yesterday we had a symposium on symmetry
in science and important role was played
by the fact that in general nature is
not symmetric but if you go to a special
situation often you know of minimal
energy or you know you can think of it
of trying to pack things in the most
regular way with or we discussed the the
shape of a soap bubble that tries to
minimize its surface tension you
typically get
symmetrical objects I in fact it's it's
efficient I mean I think that's why we
see it in flowers in in organisms so
you're basically making a point that if
our tools of design and production will
change and they are changing now where
that is some sense we see less will
probably we'll see in the future less
and less symmetrical objects are you
thinking I don't know I think it's just
there's the other big issue with
symmetry which is beauty and we'll deal
with it later so symmetry as a
merchandising or marketing tool but I
think that as we have more and more
additive design and 3d printing and the
idea so many architects and designers
are working on growing objects and
buildings as opposed to making them so
when you have a pavilion that that's
made by silkworms then you know the
symmetry will not be that important
anymore so what kind of the difference
we think about it like a crystal or
something which is just a way in which
molecules or atoms are ordered compared
to a tree yeah which grows organically
and that has a completely different kind
of shape absolutely and that's what many
actors and designers that are doing
experimental work right now are taking
as models animals that you you were
actually as an architect and leading an
architectural firm you you see this
symmetry as a as a guiding principle in
your work or is it evolving in the in
the same direction at Paula's same
technology same direction as Paula said
but in addition to that I think that was
the onset of modernism we've sort of
taken it as an intellectual concept to
defy symmetry and and I think that today
and were actually past that because if
there are reasons that symmetry is
useful so to speak if you can employ it
as a tool it was in a set of particular
circumstances then so be it as you say
so I think it's not so interesting to
say
yay or nay hey but I think it is
interesting and it sounds to me like
eventually we've gone talk about the
concept of beauty relative to symmetry
there it really gets interesting because
there are all sorts of social influences
to know as an architect I find it highly
annoying when somebody comes to me and
says I really like symmetry right thank
you
was that the reason why you came to this
performance norwich so since we now
already said three times we will discuss
about it I think we should talk about
beauty beauty and my favorite line is
that now if you talk about symmetry with
mathematicians or physicists they
immediately will say oh it's beautiful
and there is not a little hint of irony
in using that word actually my thesis is
that the word beauty is only used
without any conditions in a very naive
fashion in science no it's in our design
or something you have to put quotation
marks here to discuss it we are still in
this very naive
ancient times where we just think it's
the highest happiness to to describe so
how come
so let's first discuss this point or why
the association between beauty and
symmetry before we go to kind of perhaps
take a view what happened no the last
hundred years or something but if you
say something but why do we even
associate the word beauty with
symmetrical objects is any biological
where they were attracted to as human
beings we used to be attracted in
history to Sigma symmetry for reasons
maybe that had to do with like optimal
procreation I don't know but it's a
flower you know I'm not agreeing with
the flowers only symmetrical ourselves
yes
to start with there is a degree of
comfort and comfort and
familiarity I think with the idea of
symmetry this is by the way a kind of a
universal cultural phenomena absolutely
and all at pops yes I think that the
word is Greek right
you know symmetry Oh symmetry yeah we're
still on symmetry sorry and it means it
includes proportions and balances in
dimensional understanding or or in a
dimensional sense and I think that sort
of goes back to to answering your
question is that is why we why we sort
of we almost cannot do without the
concept of symmetry but then it kind of
evolves power lines so I think you know
in this very few people would use that
concept anymore because of some kind our
whole aesthetic has evolved yes I would
you well it's it's interesting that you
say that because at some point in the
world of architecture and design nobody
said the b-word for a while or scary
words and even now I have a little bit
of a hard time talking about it and then
I do openly when I have to make
statements for instance one statement
that I tend to make is that beauty is a
sign of respect towards other human
beings but then I switched to aesthetic
intention because when we're designers
or creatives today we cannot not take
into account punk and I mentioned before
pyramid over dad I mean all the all of
the instances and the parts of and the
moments in history that have led us to
go well beyond the idea of platonic
beauty so saying Beauty still it leads
us to think of the same kind of beauty
they're your friends mathematicians talk
about like you know this kind of
symmetric beauty so aesthetic aesthetic
intention let's also take into account
you know ugly fruit and
and Punk and other expressions but I do
believe that giving making effort
putting effort into the formal aspect of
any kind of object is a way to
communicate with other human beings so
no matter what whether it's symmetrical
or not it is something that has to be
taken into account the fact that these
objects correlate so strongly among
cultures or something is it is it
telling us something about ourselves the
fact that we universally are attracted
to these objects although we might now
have a more complicated relation
relationship to them undoubtedly but
there are some cultures and I don't know
enough maybe you know more about this
Annabel but like for instance let's go
back to Japan isn't a lack of symmetry
praised a lack of balance praised are
not necessarily so well I think it it's
certainly that's my my understanding of
it is that it's always about the tension
of the tool right and where you put into
question the familiarity the formality
the the the the commonality if you will
of of symmetry with something that puts
that into question I think that's where
that happens and scientifically does
symmetry create tension or not or it's
the killing of all tensions well I think
that the big difference mean from a
scientific point of view is to look at
the symmetry in an object something
which could kind of be boring in the
sense you know triangle or something
it's not the most beautiful object
that's out there but I think we're
mathematicians and physicists start to
kind of resonate if if you see that your
theory or something is symmetrical that
you see we have I think it's almost but
it's it's it's I would say it's almost
synonymous with power
it's the of the the power of on
standing things and one way you can
think about symmetry is that it somehow
reduces the it's a there's an extra
amount of order if you look at again at
the symmetrical object if it's a round
object and you know that in some sense a
lot of the properties of that object are
a disc like described by its symmetry
the fact that you can rotate it around
and so it's it's symmetry in some sense
enhances the power of your ideas or your
theories and that's actually I think so
in that sense this sense of beauty that
is used by scientists is perhaps not
only just the aesthetic but it comes
with in some sense it's loaded with
incredible power of expression and it
has sources also to I think typically
people find an equation beautiful that's
what you are all saying you explain it
explains a lot with a very small number
of symbols it's it's that's that balance
or something does that not also imply a
sense of resolution I mean I've always
thought that that the word resolution is
actually a really interesting concept in
resolution in which a bit ray well a
beautiful equation yes implies that you
perfectly resolved ah yes a thesis right
yes and to that extent symmetry fulfills
that in in perhaps a I'm sort of inept
finding the right words but it seems to
me that there is a sort of elegance
about that resolution yes that may be
very satisfactory so perhaps I think you
know one explanation could be that
scientists are so unashamed to word
beauty is that they they actually have a
different sense of beauty than just that
they like something or they would like
to display it or something because you
know probably the object themselves are
boring but it's the it's the power of
perhaps me you in the way you could
describe there's a certain movement in
art is beautiful because it has been you
know so creative and created so much
might be a different Liberia's cuz
actually when it comes to the formal
beauty sometimes they're a little yeah a
little uncomfortable we're discussing
before the b-word I think this might be
a good moment to take a few questions
and what I want to do is just let me put
some light on the room I don't see
anything at yeah but we have microphones
I just learned up and I want to take a
few questions but just raise your hands
I can't see anything turn the lights on
okay good
so our roving mics you are perfect yes I
will take a few questions I then present
them to the to the panel yes please go
ahead sure so I guess through the
history of our our species
what advancements do you think the first
straight line gave to our made and found
objects thank you and other questions
yes over there please my question is
symmetry in say music like harmony and
melody or even in visual aesthetics how
can you represent that in other purple
means like there is how many and melody
in music for example or even artists
like that these paintings the way it
blends like there's some sort of a
harmony is that a kind of symmetry and
is there any other way to represent it
good comes back to the theme of of
proportion I think this is there not a
question at this point they are in the
back all right yes sir yes QP so I think
Google just released something where
they use AI to create art my question to
you is if you were to design algorithm
to create art or to not
deterministically create art but come up
with its own theory of art how would you
do that what would you do and how would
you incorporate symmetry into that
excellent and
I think we yeah we often talk about
symmetry visually and I'm wondering if
we could discuss symmetry through the
other senses like feeling or smell or
taste perfect yes one more and let me go
back to the panel in discussions about
surgery there's been words like
efficiency or even resolution that's
been brought up and one word that I was
curious about is the idea of essence in
and through the idea of design and I was
wondering if that would be an
interesting topic for for you guys to
talk about as well terrific well thank
you very much so we reach arts the
conversation I want to start with the
first question
Edward about the the the first straight
line just a little anecdote I have a
colleague of mine and he tells the story
I think he was like 6 years old and was
in school and the teacher tried to
explain some basic geometry and he draw
a line chalk line on the blackboard and
he said well this is a line now in in
theory it's infinitely long and
infinitely thin but clearly that's not
possible and then my friend raised his
hand and he said well we know but in our
minds we can think about an infinitely
long line and then I think he was sent
out of the class because it was a poor
guy he's became very successful
businesses but he's so right so I want
that to turn that question around you're
just at some point and I find it still
amazing that you know some we can
actually even the six-year-old can think
of the concept of an infinitely long
line I think if you think all of you if
you think about a line a mathematical
line going on forever I don't think
nobody of us has problem with it
although now our mind is finite and the
world we see is finite it's very easy to
imagine the hardest thing about it is
that there's always a moment when it
starts yes it's
the the the infinity of it is not as
difficult as it started but I want to
turn this room in this in some sense
it's almost going back to Plato and this
images so with its friends easy to if
your thing think about the circle we
think about the circle so both you would
how does that and we don't know when we
first thought about is but clearly it's
very easy to think of these concepts
what is the role of these kind of mental
almost mathematical concepts and the
actual said in architecture is that
somehow it doesn't play a role or we
need Skelly attention beador but how did
that change our view of the world well I
think it's a perpetual change right as
as we become familiar with concepts
generally talked about this learning yes
we can develop and evolve our way of
thinking I mean to me the the question
of the straight line is actually a
really interesting one because because
it's the do perhaps it's that we think a
straight line is the opposite of an
organic line or an organic because it's
we don't see them in real life right in
if you walk through the jungle there's
very few straight lines well except that
you do where where gravity plays a role
right like if you have a spider drops
mm-hmm a thing it goes down in a
straight line and and I think our
experience of straightness is actually
something that is very profound and very
old yeah don't know where it started but
your thoughts about it I we've always
been able to imagine a straight line but
it's been really hard to make it happen
like we always know what we want but our
tools are imperfect and there's a great
exhibition that is open right now in
Milan that is called the prehistory of
design which shows something that I've
always believed that design started when
we made our first tools and and
it goes all the way to today and there's
some AI ideas it's really beautiful but
so there's no not much distance between
the first sphere and the AI object it's
just that we've been laboring for so
many centuries to get better tools to
get there so that's really the point you
feel that in some sense meant people
were making these first tools that these
mental concepts of almost mathematical
concepts that are in our mind were we're
guiding them is that it's um is there
some sense of empowerment when you make
something which is close to this
Platonic image or close to something
instead that is completely non platonic
and that is not even a Euclidean because
you've gone through the different steps
in history that led you to believe that
the goal is not anymore the Platonic
line or the Platonic idea so we we
follow our destiny we develop and mature
and make our mistakes as humanity all
together
and let every single moment we have an
idea of what we want to do and we have
this eternal frustration of not being
able to make it exactly the way we want
because our tools are imperfect so
that's the tension that I feel exists
well I think that's I mean it's it's
something that I mean oh I have to say
something about because indeed you know
it's kind of amazing that with all the
examples all the pictures we show
anything we point out that we think is a
symmetric object it's not because if you
look close it's not these exhibitions
the coils nothing they're not really
symmetric they remind us of these
platonic images and I think nobody can
print out a perfect square a perfect
circle if you look up close you see
little bumps no it's always so we have
to work live with these kind of failures
but that's only if if the concept of
failure is is interesting yeah that
because I think in the first place we
think of it as a concept and similar to
being able to thinking about the
infinite line yes if you can think of
the perfect square
it gets you a long way at least four
architected yes I want to come back to a
certain second theme that was mentioned
by the banner audience which is indeed
the fact that we kind of very
one-dimensional in the sense we have
been really talking about the visual
experience while I think you know
certainly the arts and just the way we
relate to the world is different music
was mentioned in fact again from a
scientific point of view
if you look at the power of symmetry we
said well there's power we think of
symmetry as movement turning something
around or making inverting it or
shifting it but in fact another way to
actively do something with an object is
moving it in time no and and the way the
nature is for instance invariant under
translation to time in the fact that the
laws of nature do not change minute by
minute in fact we think they are eternal
is is a very powerful principle again in
physics something that we find beautiful
and and music was mentioned where of
course you you experience am anyway the
same kind of patterns that you see in
design there was a suggestion what about
the other senses if there is any how do
you want to try to dare to step in this
kind of multi multi sensual experience
of it's so it's so huge so several years
ago together with the collaborator
colleague of mine Jerry hunt we did a a
symposium at Parsons that was called
headspace and it was about senses
headspace headspace is a technology that
is used in the perfume industry to
capture the scent of living beings
without damaging them so usually you do
it with camellias and and you have to
explain that again so it you it's to
capture molecules of scent from things
from objects from flowers without
damaging them what it's it's almost like
a cupping like you know when you do
capping in Chinese acupuncture and then
it's connected to machinery that use a
spectrometer so you replicate the
molecule yeah and then you and then you
replicate them so that's it's called
headspace technology so we called it
headspace and it was about sent as a
form of design so we had a whole day
long
architects and all of these great
perfumers but the interesting thing is
that we are signed some perfumers from
iff which is international flavors and
fragrances so they usually work for like
a mess or like you know they work for
big companies and we have signed them
with some architects to create
custom-made scent and one in particular
a team of two great perfumers French
like French perfumers like noses were
assigned to majora Carter that's an
activist friend of mine from the Bronx
to create the perfect scent of the South
Bronx so it was fantastic there were
like these videos that were hilarious of
them arriving in Li MO and the South
Bronx it was just so funny
but everybody enjoyed it tremendously
but what I learned from that experience
is that of course we tend to never think
of off scent that way but it's an
algorithm it's a it's a composition of
different molecules and this big
fragrance companies of course generate
all sorts of artificial fragrances but
then there are some molecules that they
develop and patent that are the most
expensive one the ones that get them
Millions that exists only to enhance and
and create a lack of symmetry like you
know just create the tension that you
were discussing before between other
molecules so what I've come to discover
is that scent both in static and in
dynamic terms the way it starts and it
has a head and a tail blah blah blah
like whisky is really about the
evolution in time and it's about
creating the tension that is in my
ignorant mind non-symmetrical but then
you know sometimes when you talk about
the symmetry music that develops over
time I'm a little lost so maybe there's
a symmetry also to scent but death
the non symmetry seems more interesting
to so many perfumers one association I
immediately have is that because scent
is such a refined notion because it
actually acts out the individual
molecules right I mean it has so many
dimensions too much more than just say
sound or something and in fact these
molecules are all you know are very very
kind of usually asymmetric so if you
take the mirror image of these molecules
you will actually they won't produce get
something completely different
for you I was also thinking in terms of
yes please I read somewhere that as a
thesis that symmetry represents the
defying memory whereas a symmetry
supports many reasons and I think that's
really interesting in that particular
instance especially because in that an
asymmetric object doesn't remember it
because it's like asymmetrical so I mean
I concluded from that that that comes to
be because it's more individual and
incomparable to something that is
immediately understandable but that's
certainly with respect to suit makes a
lot of sense I ask you in terms of
architecture and buildings what are the
other senses are something that are part
of the experience of a building is it
it's not only individual well I think
tactility and we'll send a little bit
but touch yes oh I guess ductility and
touch the same thing but sound of course
sound I think is incredibly important
and reverberation and I think that in
different from music and most music is
written and therefore the sort of idea
of some symmetry in music makes some
sense to me because it can occur as part
of repetition or it's a sort of
translation of the visual into something
else
whereas mirror sound I don't know that
that is symmetrical connected also but
the question was the concept of harmony
was brought up and we were very talked
about balance and harmony harmony I
think might be similar the H words or
something - you know these are concept
that again had a very kind of platonic
beginning and kind of evolved I think
actually we are entitled with our
discussion of symmetry to kind of move
in that direction I think there so I
want to talk a little bit about the
concept of balance and harmony and which
which I think goes beyond symmetry or
something but it's a it's honourable you
mentioned proportions of course there's
a long-standing tradition also kind of
try to capture these proportions in
numbers in mathematical numbers or
famous numbers are ancient times the
golden ratio various ways in which
mathematical formula is trying to
capture these notions of balance and
harmony you feel that we talked about
kind of symmetry as kind of evolving
it's no longer our Platonic goal and we
a lot of it is about the tension with it
its balance and harmony still in
architecture in perhaps in your work
it's something you strive for or and if
so how would you how do you capture it
well that's a big one
I remember reading an article a long
time ago where REM koolhaas said that
striving for brutality in architecture
was a very important concept and its
brutality the opposite of harmony or
well it's in the sense I think it is
yeah
and unbalanced I right exactly lack of
balance I struggled with that statement
then and I do today because I actually
think there is plenty of lack of balance
and lack of harmony in our lives as it
is so providing the opposite providing a
kind of meditational quiet is something
that I think is desirable having said
that it can't happen without tension it
can't happen if it's not held in a in a
sort of I don't know precious precious
separation or something like that so
right this concept of balance and
they're just proportion are something
which can be kind of almost like
calculated you think is there some kind
of are the certain laws there is there
some order in what makes something
balance in order that evolving obviously
there are laws and order then that
minute it's predictable and I think that
is what would disrupt the idea of
harmony or balance I think you see a
when you experience a beautiful
proportion you immediately have a sense
of balance or a sense of of well-being
and that is not a bad thing but I think
it's too simple to say that that's all
there is you can't you know it can't it
can't come to two two perfections how to
speak if it's not held by something else
does that make sense yeah I was thinking
that all the designers that I know from
furniture designers to visualization
designers nobody thinks of balance in
harmony
nobody no no not anybody that I can
think of the goals
different and you know design what
happened that at some point in the
history of design that was kind of far
not sure that it was ever the goal for
design mean many people argue that
design was born with the Industrial
Revolution as I mentioned to you before
it was to me much efficiency much older
than that but harmony maybe can happen
can be a important in some ritualistic
tools right so you were talking before
about the meditative spaces so there are
some tools that that me I'm meant to but
there are the goal is harmony because
the goal of their use is harmony you
know what I'm saying so for these
particular objects then it's important
otherwise I'm thinking of furniture
designers right now some deal want to
have comfort others want to have the
demonstration of a new technology that
enables one to make knots and solidify
them in a chair so the goals are
different hardly ever are the goals are
money for the sake of it I mean some
sense yes yeah I think again similar to
the word symmetry it doesn't describe
the objective that may be it may be an
inherent gold goal to try to to strive
for harmony because the intelligence of
the act of making a particular object
includes that but I think that it's not
solely that right no I agree since we
have several times where we mentioned
the fact kind of that have some much
more interesting topic it's a symmetry
is the fact that a distension with and I
think there's a long tradition dare to I
mean I think we have some images of
these kind of wonderful Islamic art
tilings you know where your day and
that's actually quite lovely
the frenzied alambre you see these
wonderful tilings and I think they were
done in a kind of a experimental fashion
design is trying to find all possible
patterns and mathematicians now know
that's one useful fact for all of you to
take home that are exactly 17 different
kind of wallpaper patterns if you try to
build a different kind of wallpaper
patterns and I think all 17 are you can
find them but I think there is a usually
phenomena that is these decorations are
done in an almost perfect way because
there's always a small way in which it
it's definitely you have to tweak it for
so what is our fascination with that
kind of asymmetry the cheating just is
yes fascination is but I was thinking
that even one of the most symmetrical
pieces of design is the beanbag chair
which is my favorite piece of furniture
right but it starts as symmetrical in
order to accommodate any kind of
asymmetry all right yes so do you think
of the beanbag line there is a person
yeah so I think that we love cheating
there's nothing better when you're
creating something that's to start with
a rule and then just start seeing what
happens when you start cheating yes
well because I think that's creativity
right I I don't think of creativity as a
process that is about following the
rules and I don't mean I don't even want
to romanticize breaking the rules it's
not something that has to do with an
infantile position but it's really about
finding new new paths every moment do
you think then again going back to the
the symmetry perhaps also as kind of a
metaphor for a very ordered organized
world that we need that some sense as a
background in order to make our verb
mean in some sense are we talking about
variations on kind of a theme that is by
itself perhaps kind of boring and
discarded entities fighting against your
your father or your mother in order to
grow yes like the rules that's why the
question about the algorithm was also
incredibly interesting because yesterday
after hearing the panel that you were
part of after hearing all the scientists
talk about the symmetry in equations I
went home and I and I started thinking
of the symmetry and algorithm algorithms
are not symmetrical
they are recipes that are just starters
for sometimes unpredictable evolutions
and I was trying to think whether the
algorithm is the opposite of the
equation in this idea of symmetry and
asymmetry so I'm asking you what do you
think
well it's quite interesting to ask about
kind of symmetry in kind of equations
because now I'd love to say that if you
have an equation you know the most part
which typically looks something like a
equals B or something about that you
know usually not enough attention is
given to the equal sign you know because
it's like always about a and B and the
equal sign I love it it's actually
perfectly symmetric and I will think of
it is as a as a double cord cable
connecting a and B and it connects a to
B but also connects B to a and if you
take some of the most powerful equations
in physics so I think perhaps the most
famous equations equals MC squared
Einstein's equation so what is it what
does it tell us it tells is energy on
the one hand equals up to some constant
of proportionality C squared equals mass
so what does it mean you can take energy
pure energy and turn into to mass you
can create particles out of pure energy
and the other way you can take particles
and for instance as you do in a nuclear
explosion take mass and produce into
energy so it somehow takes two concepts
that were not connected it it equates
them but also it connects them it
produces a kind of a nice left-right
symmetry which in in in many ways and I
think that's why we Hoek call it
beautiful
beautiful because it's enlarges our
world it connects to parts that didn't
even need to be together and nowadays a
and B they were from different worlds
now they're together in a simple
equation in fact this is nice kind of
connecting piece of equal sign that
actually makes them talk to each other
so there is and I think that's almost
like and then I think perhaps if you
think about it you know the deepest
development perhaps in mathematics has
been over the last 100 200 years that
instead of looking at objects I think
mathematics turned to be used to be you
look at different objects the modern way
of looking at mathematics or the objects
are just the beginning the question is
what are their relations how can you go
from one to the other and what is the
relationship and so what mathematicians
came up with is a whole framework to
think about it
so ah which we call category theory and
it means that if you and that's why
symmetry came back because if you have
object you say well you have a square
you have a triangle basic known wait a
moment how can we relate these two how
can we relate a triangle to itself well
for instance by rotating at over 120
degrees so the the symmetry is actually
in terms of the relation of objects to
each other not to the object per se and
I think that is in some sense a
liberating view and I think it's very
much connected to the theme that you
were talking about - it's not so much
about individual even pieces of design
architecture it's it's how do we relate
to it and somehow having a much more
connector view of the world where it's
not only about the dots but the various
lines connecting these dots your
question about algorithm is fascinating
I don't know what a really good yeah
it's me and then it's the way I view the
question also is that well suppose we
and now I'm really jumping into the deep
but that we are know clearly our lives
are changing through science and
technology no we've been talking
something about concepts
that date from the old Greeks or these
are 2500 old old concepts but if you go
to the here and now where science and
technology is taking such an important
role where in many ways even thinking
it's machine-assisted now we're no
longer it's not just a single human
being it's human beings connected to
each other as human beings connected to
machines artificial intelligence will
play more and more important role
I think certainly I know science will
not stop and remember this is kind of
famous moment when a guy Kasparov was
first beaten by the chess computer deep
blue he said well is this the end of
chess he said no no no from now on it's
me and the machine against you know
everybody else or it's like this ain't
no really embracing this I mean are you
we can't think about science anymore
without all our instruments our
computers everything that's happening
there what happens if you just be bold
and try to look at the future and I
think that's what what the question was
hinting at
we're algorithms combined with human
efforts will probably make design what
do you see so that's already happening
it's I see it more and more as I was
mentioning before this idea that so many
architects and designers are trying to
grow objects instead of making them from
the top down is based on the idea of
algorithm I don't know whether an
algorithm can create art because I don't
know what art is but I know that there
are artists that are doing so all the
time if the algorithm says it's art yeah
I just that's the big question that I
deal with but that's happening already
all the time it's happening in the
digital space it's happening on paper
it's happening in the 3d world and in
the 5d world so it's already 550 world
you know five days what is used by some
production designers as a world building
idea so the 5d
created well because it's um it's it's
in the digital space but it's definitely
about world building that there's
architecture in it so it's Alex McDowell
there was the the production designer
for Minority Report that coined it first
and he had created this great conference
that was basically all architects and
special effects people and he was about
the idea of building worlds based on
only special effects and spatial savvy
but also narrative and game and again
it's a game so it's already happening a
lot when it comes to our space you can
talk about what's happening and where
we'll be having small questions pretty
much the last person who knows where
we're headed
I think architecture as I practices is
is that the is on its last leg but what
I think is definitely I don't think so I
think that people will always need
spaces where they feel comfortable I'm
very interested in is that the way we
get there is different many young
architects and as they're graduating are
becoming interested in game technology
and and I think that's a fantastic thing
because it adds a dynamic to how we
think about urban space and
architectural space that we haven't
really fully grappled ultimately I think
everything happens at a moment where
somebody needs to make a decision it's
not that algorithms are going to decide
whether something is art or not maybe it
won't be the two of us either the three
of us but but the but the decision in
the conversation lies with the people
right so how we use our tools and how we
advance to another level and and I think
that is the fifth dimension that you're
talking about fascinating I think you
know if you look at what's happening in
the world of science and again I think
we're going through the same kind of
transition in the
that no I would say in the old days you
know it's when you were we were
basically looking at nature and studying
nature and looking at what are the
natural objects that we find biologists
would study all kind of organism
geologists would go around and find all
kind of rocks and look at crystal
structures etc now now that we
understand the building blocks both of
matter and of living matter it's no more
about understanding the objects that are
around us but no no we are studying the
space of all possible objects which is
vastly superior minha I think Richard
Dawkins made this point that if you look
at every object and every organism ever
lived on planet Earth and Luke is some
even on the kind of the DNA code that
came with all these organisms that's a
totally marginal fraction of all
possible DNA so no each of us know are
extremely lucky because we although the
one design that actually was executed
and ours actually was produced but this
this mental space and I think we are in
both in in in the life sciences with
synthetic biology and in the in say the
study of materials in terms of knowledge
about nanotechnology we're just
beginning to explore that space and I
think we have we need completely
different framework to approach that
space because you can't do just
everything you have to find your way
through this infinite space of
possibilities which is much more of
course we're designed and artists at the
moment you take your pen and you put it
on paper you're already drawing
something that nobody has drawn before
very true there's such great
collaborations that have been happening
for the past eight almost ten years
between synthetic biologists and either
other scientists and designers it's
fascinating
let me phrase it like this is there
anything that the scientific world has
to learn from the world design or
architecture to kind of deal with that
kind of infinitude of possible
of course and it's already happening and
it's not really like learning it's about
collaborating like there's been one of
the schools that in the past has done
the most is the Royal College of Art in
London there used to be this course
called in design interactions it was a
name but in true
it was speculative design so the
designers they were all graduate
students and they were what speculative
design it's about what if so speculative
design what if that speculative design
is about building scenarios that are
usually based on objects that talk about
the possible consequences tomorrow of
our choices of today so they would work
especially with the scientists at
Imperial College because they were
around the corner but to give you to
give an example one of my favorite
objects was this menstruation machine so
it was a contraption that enabled men or
other non menstruating beings to really
experience the menstruation also with
the cramps yeah exactly so that was an
example of an object or another year
there was a beautiful collaboration with
another highly experimental school of
design that does biology that is at in
Perth at UWA so the in an in Perth they
have developed the head they were among
the ones that had developed in vitro
meat and in London the designers were
thinking of the steak of tomorrow like
if you can develop meat in vitro watch
the steak look like so this
collaboration and also there's another
designer
Daisy Ginsburg but that's been working a
lot with Drew endy who's a synthetic
biologist at Stanford University so it's
beautiful beautiful to see what kind of
collaboration use the B word the
collaborations that are happening
between scientists and designers are
fantastic and I think that the reason
why designers want to work with
scientists it's a no-brainer but
scientists were initially diffident but
now love it because when they're working
with designers they can get out a little
bit of the peer review system that makes
them sometime timid you know nobody will
think of these projects as
replicable scientifically accurate they
are speculative once again and I don't
think that scientists speculate enough
all my string theorists are thinking
that they are there are some very
directly applicable areas where science
comes together with design and
architecture and that is lighting likely
yes I mean we perpetually look for new
ways to improve artificial lighting be
great to improve understand but for
example there is this Italian scientist
who just came up with a technology to to
create light as we read as we truly
experience it it's an LED based system I
should be able to describe it better
than I can but it's essentially offering
the possibility to create natural light
in an artificially and it's fascinating
because if that really happens you can
build skylights in your basement and if
you think about the new possibilities
that that is going to to have for the
built environment it is strictly amazing
so I think you're ready swallowing your
words up the last lack that you're
standing on because it looked like the
beginning of an exciting story I want to
kind of give the audience one more
opportunity so we're gonna struggle with
the lights we try to bring them on and
do another round of questions that's
managed to do that think about questions
and raise your hands there's anything
you've been so good so far with the
questions yes or more yes I so one would
think of the extra the representations
physical representations in the world
the arts architecture as a reflection of
the brain
self and how do you think of symmetry in
the sense of the representation of our
minds and it's manifestation in the
world and and and how that kind of
feedback loop happens I know this is
kind of a big question but I'm trying to
maybe think of how our minds play a role
and a good question the brain and the
mind other questions here it could be
quite general about the interplay of
science and art over there yes yeah
sorry it's a same question that a
similar to question that I asked last
time I was just thinking that you have a
straight line and in a sound like
suppose Buddhist constant sound be a
straight line and what would be a sound
that is like a circle like a sound that
repeats itself and can you add them to
like it like a cylinder or you know
parametric just you know going on that
part of how do you represent different
similar like symmetries thank you
okay that's a question over there Thanks
I remember you mentioning earlier about
this 5d thing could you elaborate on
that
I guess want to understand by the five
comes from is that the a better
definition good good any other questions
yes what would you think and this is
probably an interaction of physics and
symmetry if there was an absence of
physics or physical laws how would that
change the idea of symmetry and what you
would define as symmetry
mmm interesting question and one more
the last one there in the back
this is kind of a weird question but
when I think of symmetry I even think of
like infinite fractals and like infinite
structures mm-hmm
do you think symmetry would exist
without like infinity and like do you
think because with like most Observatory
things being finite do you think like
but I think we can understand if
necessary good good question okay we'll
turn back to our distinguished panel I
think we are still confused about the
definition of 5d I don't want to say
something wrong so I think the best
would be to go to the website and see I
can I can describe what it was and
without giving a definition so when he
was founded the first time this 5d in
Institute was the idea to have the three
dimensions of the space plus time plus
also the idea of all the different
parallel lives and worlds that you can
have in a video game as Annabelle
rightly pointed out and in a space that
is connected digital and physical so it
was a way to to think of the worlds that
one can build in the digital space and
connecting them also to the physical
world so what Alex McDowell did he's he
founded this conference where as I
mentioned to you was like game video
game designer special effects people and
architects because there's really a need
for architectural savvy in the digital
space and then now he has an institute
at the university of southern california
lasondra is called world building in
which he uses people that do special
effects and the do gaming and then
architecture students and also urban
design students and they apply their
skills to the resolution of instances
like there's a Makoto that is an
an area in Lagos Nigeria that is all on
stilts that is on the water and they're
trying to use the world building
Institute skills so architecture plus
urban design plus the ability to create
whole worlds and narratives in the
digital space to address issues in them
but in that particular location so I
know that I haven't answered the perfect
definition and I'm doing that I'm not
answering in order not to do injustice
to the concept so if you don't mind
looking at looking it up later on the 5d
Conference and 5d Institute and Alex
McDowell you'll find they're the perfect
definition but it's really practicing
architecture and urban planning using
all the tools at our disposal today in a
particular way great thank you and also
I feel perhaps it should answer the
question about music because it was ours
twice and so one way to think about the
symmetries in music they have course to
do with the symmetries in time but
actually and kind of convenient way to
think about it think about a the way the
music is written in in the music score
so you can think of a music score
essentially as a band of music and you
can see certain patterns for instance if
you have a repeating phrase it looks
almost like one of these kind of
beautiful tilings that we saw behind us
or freezes as they are used in
architecture at the musical music
written by Bach yes that's incredibly
interesting because it's an intensely
visual experience of sound yeah but
anyway sorry you know you're totally
right and I think sometimes these kind
of scores that you use beautiful they
look beautiful I mean they have actually
these symmetries you see them repeating
not quite the same
sometimes you see inversion so the
reflection symmetry could there be two
it literally was a trick in in composing
to take a phrase and just kind of turn
it around so upside down essentially a
natural to think about it it's perhaps
now if you think about the circle you
set room it's very difficult to see
circles in real life but in some sense
they are offered where around us because
as soon as you have something that's
periodic something curves up and down
can be as a tone a musical note but it
could be anything it could basically be
the movement of the Sun and the planets
so of course they are moving on orbits
that to a great precision are circles
and so in some sense anything that is
periodic in life and if you think about
it almost everything is is in some sense
an expression of symmetry because it's
repeating itself in the same way as a
checkerboard pattern or freezer is
repeating itself so if you think about
like that way invariance under movements
in time are are all around us and in
some sense it's perhaps a more even more
you know I think deeply ingrained
experience in our brain to have
something that comes and returns because
that's know every day come comes and
goes and many of I experience so there's
a lot of symmetry in our lives we can
apply this also to coding I'm thinking
there's a beautiful visualization that
Ben Frey is a great visualization
designer did the pac-man code he
visualized and it almost looks like like
music so you see the different the
different code and then he literally
showed where the code says go back to
and reiterate and the same kind of
visual you can it's a great way to some
sense use kind of our different senses
or related to and expresses in all of
those cases it seems that one that
repetition isn't important yes yes
that's true and what was someone to go
to the question about fractals and it's
it's a very I think most of you know
fractals or at this concept that if you
zoom in they are the same or at least as
a variation
something so it has this no fascinating
concept of infinity because you can zoom
in zoom in zoom in it kind of never
stops the kind of concept of symmetry
that's involved there is a deeper kind
of symmetry symmetry that you know as
one both of you to reflect upon which is
the symmetry of a different kind of
motion it's the motion of zooming in
zooming art so it's different from going
to the left or right or think about you
have a picture you can shift it you can
rotate it you can reflect it but you can
also zoom in and zoom out and it has to
do again with scale the various scales
on which we see things a fractal is
amazing because it's it's the equivalent
of this mental image of an infinite long
line that goes on and on or the
checkerboard pattern that goes on and on
it's perfectly symmetric of course a
real checkerboard will not and but power
can you say something about this concept
of scale and the way we think of
invariants on the scaling but perhaps
also can breaking that symmetry
important element in design you'll be
amazed how much people in the design and
architectural world know about scale
because there's them not only because of
that but there's a very famous movie by
the Charles and Ray Eames the powers of
10 no wonder so it's something that
every architecture and design person I
don't you seen it please look at it
online and it's a 10 minutes movie and
it captures basically everything we know
about it it's perfectly executed and I'm
also going to make you smile because my
thesis was entitled fractal architecture
and it was this idea that by having by
overlaying a digital space and mixing it
with the physical we can really go
through scales of a very different kind
in architecture so I think it's
happening a lot there was there are two
architects been around and Chris slash
that published a pamphlet a Princeton
Architectural pamphlet in the
I think it was 2007 that was all about
all the different stratagems that one
can use in parametric architecture to
build so there was tiling the world by
ruling and so on and so forth and in a
way it was an attempt to take fractal
geometry and distilled into laws that
could be applied to Architecture and
then built by computer so it's something
that is absolutely that is very much
used by architects and also by urban
planners there's been a lot of scale
study that moved away from simply the
building and went to the city the
territory the nation and and computers
have helped us once again make this jump
in scale as I said something that this
powers of 10 is a beautiful but it
actually dates another this my Dutch
prize it doesn't wasn't Dutch physicist
who later became an educator and in case
Buca and he first thought of this powers
of 10 it's a beautiful book it's the
same thing it's like it's actually an
image of a woman sitting with a baby in
a in a young child in a garden somewhere
in the middle of the Netherlands and
then his whom citizens rooms are zoom
art but what I loved is that he created
his school the very plants and it was a
experimental school and he wanted to
explain the notion of scale to children
and the first design thing they had to
do is to draw a brick on a one-to-one
scale now the thing is that we all have
drawn a break you know withdrawn houses
drawn a break I've never drawn a break
on a one-to-one scrap because it's big
you know so the first thing they had to
do is to draw this large brick and it's
actually one-on-one it's very rare that
you draw anything well perhaps if you
draw your hand that's like an every
child has done that and so for him it
was not only to think in these different
scales but also to kind of ground you at
the one-to-one scale which is actually
in some sense I find that kind of a
lovely image because it really
the funny thing is that now with virtual
reality you can put yourself in the
architecture and perceive it as
one-to-one you know you're the one
that's not one anymore
you're stronger or you are but it really
it really is happening and I think
that's also there's a is some danger
with that because I think that danger
with Walt we'll see with the with the
ability of putting ourselves and onto
multiple scales the loss of the
experience of what you just described is
is magnified I think I observed that
anyway in in as a as a practicing
architect that the the direct
understanding that happened at one time
through drawing by hand the experience
of of the dimension is becomes more and
more remote and becomes more and more
theoretical and as it becomes
theoretical it moves away from us this
is obviously a sort of old-fashioned
argument but I think that we need to
actually find a way to do both of having
the sort of immediacy and tactility of
how thick is your shirt how tall is your
seat how large are your feet
how big is a brick - what is the
dimension of the house the city town
the country or whatever end and how to
negotiate that I think is is immensely
difficult and I feel like we have a long
ways to go to tackle that so you don't
think that the new means of reproduction
like a number to reality help well they
do and they don't I think it's a little
bit of both I mean we are enabled in
ways that are mind-boggling at the same
time
I notice how how people lose the direct
touch with the with that dimension and I
I mean very specifically dimension it's
just an observation you make because
we're so focused on on the vast amount
of things that we can do that the very
close understanding of that dimension is
difficult to grapple with so it's it's a
fascinating thing that you know we are
going all these kind of transitions now
and you know we we talk about a concept
I was thinking on the concept that we
talked about today which is the nave a
beauty of symmetry etc is something that
you probably could have talked to
somebody who left 2000 or 4000 years ago
no it's something it's it's it's it's
it's not a new topic or something on the
other hand you know particularly they're
both the world and science and art has
gone through the spectacular
developments so it's kind of it's and as
we just said no we are probably really
only at the beginning of what's going on
because no technology but completely
changed the way we approach the the both
of these fields and so I want to ask you
both to kind of speculate the kind of
discussion that we're having right now
is that is that the discussion that we
will keep on having it that kind of
tension and because I one thing I kind
of picked up in basically everything
that you said both of you said is that
you know there is these Ronnie's mental
images are these beautiful concert
platonic images which and but it create
this kind of tension what what we of
what we want to create and how the world
that we want to live in something is
that something that will kind of stay
with us or is this a subject at some
point is over now I believe it'll stay
with us a believable always feel
inadequate will always feel that we want
to do better we I it's in human nature I
hope that we will
keep having this discussion over of
course the context will change the tools
will change but we will want always want
more what is the essence then what is
the essence of that tension I think the
essence of the tension is it is never
being able to reach the ultimate goal
whether it's perfection or whether it's
saving the environment but being better
than we are it's always like we always
have a carrot in front of us so just
chasing that Platonic image platonic is
the Platonic image just don't do that
much for me anymore it's just chasing
the image of what that better would be
yes you know and maybe it's completely
not platonic
maybe it's brutal you know I say the
actual concept of this kind of
perfection is changing and evolving
unattainable yes no there's always
something more yes and I was watching
the other day there's a British woman
that I love so much she's done a lot of
body modification she's done also the
eyeball tattoo where you become the
white or the eye becomes like bright
blue and so I just went I started
browsing all these body modifications
that happened cuz I didn't know much
about it it's amazing what some human
beings put themselves through to achieve
whatever image they have that it's
definitely not platonic yes of what it
is that they want to achieve so I think
that that's a metaphor for all of us for
goal whatever we will keep on struggling
for something more and beyond yes okay
relate to that well I happen to read the
New York Times book section this weekend
and there was an article about a German
man who was born with very limited limbs
and he became fascinating to people
because he was unbelievably capable in
the course of his life youth not only
fathered 14 children but and had
multiple wives who he outlived but he
was capable of making these incredibly
sophisticated like miniature manuscripts
and there's a there is an exhibition now
I can't remember where of all of the
works that he did and why was I thinking
of that because you were talking now and
earlier about our inability to create
the perfect tools and while I think that
this this infinite struggle of course
goes on but I think in my mind the the
tension comes from from the achieving
from the Eureka moment to the having to
push the envelope to the next thing
and I think that if there wasn't every
once in a while this sort of elated
moment of saying we did achieve if not
perfection something that's very if if
we couldn't experience that have the
pleasure of the experience of nature or
the pleasure of experiencing art in its
purest way whatever that may be I think
we wouldn't be able to go to struggle to
the next thing it was Adam at that
exhibition but yeah yeah that's that's
that's right I'm really going to see if
it's actually taking you both points of
view together it's kind of a feel we're
kind of approaching perfect entities
this alone because it's what I take away
from this is that you know we are kind
of placed in between this kind of world
of perfection and symmetry and the
asymmetry in the chaos it's like this
kind of perfect place where we as human
beings can you know can define ourselves
as as struggling to to reach a certain
goal which we never reach but yet you
know we have this great gift that there
is so much order around us that makes it
makes it possible so I think I think in
terms of depth to our challenge
sorry no I was looking at the image yeah
yes pretty sure captured at all I think
you know that might be the feeling the
audience has when it was following our
dialogue but I just want to thank both
of you because clearly this was a grand
topic it could get anyway and I think in
the same way we just say that you know
we're struggling to do the impossible I
think both of you did I think you did it
very successfully and thank you so much
for enlightening us with your
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]